Kate Middleton might be a duchess but  younger sister Pippa Middleton was the  queen of Wimbledon fashion not  particularly know all we'd say so the 32  year old fashionista looked a regal  while at center court on day seven of  the Wimbledon Tennis Championships in  London England on Monday rocking a  gorgeous retro orange and gray  long-sleeve dress paired with a matching  grey handbag and pumps another fashion  royal at the event Anna Wintour who was  sitting right in front of Pippa Pippa  was also at last week's match and the  crowd almost got a different show than  the tennis match they were there to see  because princess Kate's younger sister  nearly flashed the crowd in her gorgeous  white frock with pink flowers wonder  what Anna would have said about that